es totalmente gratis así que si la
escuela tiene internet y computadoras
cualquier tipo de computadoras pueden
empezar desde 11 y llegar a cálculo
es formidable para motivarlos y para que
practiquen no volvería a enseñar como
antes si tengo esta opción
la primera vez que escuché de khan
academy lo que más me atrajo fue que iba
a ser para todos los alumnos en el nivel
que estuvieran
cuando supe que pueden trabajar a su
propio ritmo y me iba a dar más tiempo
para trabajar con grupos más pequeños me
aventé de inmediato siempre trataba de
usar cosas diferentes tener proyectos
nuevos buscaba otras formas para que
todos mis alumnos comprendieran sin
importar su nivel y siempre tuve la
sensación de que no era muy buena en
ello cuando llego khan academy en dos
semanas me di cuenta que era
sorprendente
finalmente sentí que estaba enseñando a
todos y que ninguno de mis alumnos se
aburría
a la academia ha impactado notablemente
a la mayoría de mis alumnos hay quienes
buscan alcanzar metas altas que lo usan
para avanzar les atrae las matemáticas
quieren explorar nuevas cosas y tienen
la habilidad para hacerlo
también hay alumnos que les cuesta
trabajo que todavía batallan con
matemáticas elementales que no han
dominado los conceptos de 3º o 4º grado
y esto les permite regresar a ellos y
llenar esos vacíos para que tengan unas
bases sólidas todo se reduce a cuál es
el beneficio para el alumno y el
beneficio para el maestro en ese orden
khan academy les da a los alumnos las
instrucciones el aprendizaje que
necesitan al nivel donde se encuentran
en el tiempo en que lo necesitan la
información en la base de datos me
permite dividir a los alumnos en grupos
puedo enfocarme en aquellos alumnos que
están batallando en áreas específicas
también puedo ver al grupo como un todo
por ejemplo si la clase completo un
módulo y ya domina en un tema antes de
que yo lo aborde en clase sé que no
necesito dedicarle tanto tiempo así que
como maestro implica tiempo liberado
para usarlo con mayor eficiencia
ha cambiado a mis alumnos son más
responsables y saben dónde están parados
definitivamente se dan cuenta si saben
algo o no lo expresan y le dedican
tiempo a ellos mismos a mí me ha
cambiado porque ahora sé mucho más de
mis alumnos
algo que kan ha cambiado dramáticamente
es que ahora están aprendiendo procesos
de manera correcta no nada más pasar por
pasar
lo ven como un juego de vídeo en un
juego de vídeo te equivocas a menudo lo
que hemos visto es que los alumnos
aprenden de sus errores antes de que sea
demasiado tarde lo superan y aprenden
las matemáticas en vez de seguir
fingiendo que las entiende ayuda porque
ahora puedo localizar ciertas áreas a
veces pueden pasar semanas completas sin
saber que algún alumno no comprendió
algo dos capítulos atrás pero con khan
academy eso sale a la luz más seguido y
puedes corregirlo y salvar el día
en realidad hemos tenido más tiempo para
realizar proyectos y otra serie de
actividades que están fuera del libro de
matemáticas y es fantástico porque es
aquí donde los chicos verdaderamente
aprenden y lo disfrutan estos chicos
están en verdad concentrados en lo que
hacen están aplicando lo que aprenden en
matemáticas en diferentes situaciones y
tienen oportunidad de trabajar uno a uno
o en pequeños grupos conmigo y podemos
tener conversaciones sobre matemáticas
que de verdad contribuyen a su
aprendizaje ahora que están tan
involucrados para mí es un reto mayor
ser profesor de matemáticas porque tengo
que encontrar formas de llevarlos a
conocimientos más profundos resolver
problemas más difíciles porque les
interesa y están listos la enseñanza de
las matemáticas ahora es más atractiva y
participativa